♪
>> Tammy: EVER WONDER BOY THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T STOP THE CRISIS
AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
TURN THOSE IMMIGRANT IN
DEMOCRATIC VOTES REGARDLESS OF
CITIZENSHIP "NEW YORK TIMES" OUT
WITH A ESSAY NO GOOD REASON YOU
SHOULD HAVE TO BE A CITIZEN TO
VOTE.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO JOURNALIST
ABRA HERMINEY.
SHE GOES ON TO WRITE IT'S TIME
FOR DEMOCRATS TO RADICALLY
EXPAND THE ELECTORATE.
SHE IS NOT ASHAMED TO ADMIT
DEMOCRATS ARE LIKELY TO BE THE
BIGGEST BENEFICIARIES OF THIS
CHANGE.
HERE TO EXPLAIN THE PIT FALLS OF
VOTING.
STEPHEN MILLER AMERICAN FIRST
LEGAL FOUNDER AND FORMER -- IT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LET'S SKIP ALL THOSE OTHER STEPS
OR PRETEND WOULD HE GO ARE GOING
TO IMPORT VOTERS AND IMPORT
CITIZENS.
FORGET THAT PART.
THEY DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THAT,
DO THEY.
>> THE "NEW YORK TIMES" OPINION
PIECE IS EXTRAORDINARILY
REVEALING FOR THE MINDSET OF THE
LEFT.
WHICH IS THEY WANT TO ERODE AND
ULTIMATELY ERASE THE VERY IDEA
OF AMERICAN CITIZENSHIP.
VOTING IS NOT JUST A RIGHT.
IT'S ALSO A RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU HAVE TO LEARN OUR COUNTRY'S
HISTORY, ITS CULTURE, ITS
LANGUAGE, ITS VALUES.
IF YOU WANT TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT VOTING.
THAT'S WHY THIS COUNTRY HAS A
NATURALIZATION PROCESS.
A LAWFUL PROCESS TO GO THROUGH,
TO LEARN WHO WE'RE AND WHAT WE
ARE ABOUT.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DID DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTUALLY BEEN
REVERSED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN,
WHICH WE ACTUALLY IMPROVED AND
UPGRADED THE NATURALIZATION
PROCESS TO PUT A GREATER
EMPHASIS ON AMERICAN HISTORY AND
AMERICAN VALUES.
>> Tammy: YOU KNOW, WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS PART OF BECOMING
AN AMERICAN, AND YOU SEE THIS
WITH PEOPLE AS THEY ARE SWORN
IN, IS THAT COMMITMENT, IS
PEOPLE COME HERE NOT BECAUSE THE
WEATHER IS GREAT.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY WANT TO BECOME
AN AMERICAN.
THERE IS A TRANSITION THAT
HAPPENS.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE IN YOUR D.N.A.
THERE IS THE FREEDOM BECOMES
PALPABLE AND CLEAR.
IF THAT'S -- IF WE ARE GOING TO
ERASE THAT, THEN EFFECTIVELY,
THERE IS NO COUNTRY.
THERE IS NO SOVEREIGNTY.
THERE IS NO AMERICA WITHIN WHICH
TO BECOME A PART OF, IS THERE?
>> WHICH IS THE ENTIRE GOAL.
YOU KNOW, WHEN SUSAN RICE, WHO
IS CURRENTLY THE HEAD OF THE
DOMESTIC POLICY COUNCIL, WHICH
MEANS SHE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING IMMIGRATION AND
POLICY IN THE UNITED STATES,
WHEN WHEN SHE SAYS WHAT SHE DID
A FEW DAYS AGO THAT DREAMERS ARE
AMERICANS.
SHE IS ENGAGED IN PURPOSEFUL
LYING.
AND SHE IS ENGAGED IN AN ATTACK
ON THE ENGLISH LANGUAGE.
AMERICANS ARE AMERICANS.
CITIZENS ARE CITIZENS.
AND DREAMERS, SO-CALLED, ARE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
AND WHEN WE DEPRIVE PEOPLE OF
THIS COUNTRY OF THEIR LANGUAGE,
OF THEIR ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK CLEARLY AND SAY NO, IF YOU
COME HERE ILLEGALLY YOU ARE NOT
A CITIZEN.
YOU ARE NOT AN AMERICAN, YOU
DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN
OUR ELECTIONS, YOU DO NOT HAVE
THE RIGHT TO OCCUPY AMERICAN
JOBS.
THESE ARE NOT CONTROVERSIAL
THOUGHTS.
THESE ARE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL
IDEAS TO WHAT IT MEANS TO HAVE
AND TO KEEP A NATION.
>> Tammy: SEE, WE'RE A NATION
THAT'S BASED ON AN IDEA.
AND IT MAKES A RESULT EASIER TO
KIND OF SQUASH THAT IDEA WITH
CHANGING THE LANGUAGE, MAKING
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
RIGHTS, THE RIGHT TO VOTE AS A
CITIZEN.
THAT'S THE THING THAT WE HAVE.
AND, IN THE MEAN TIME, I KNOW
THAT YOU I BELIEVE JUST FILED A
LAWSUIT.
THROUGH YOUR FOUNDATION, YOUR
LEGAL FOUNDATION, THAT DEALS
WITH THE RACE BASED SUPPORT FOR
FARMERS.
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT?
>> WELL, I'M PROUD TO DISCUSS
THIS EXCLUSIVELY TONIGHT WITH
YOU AND YOUR VIEWING AUDIENCE.
HOT OFF THE PRESSES WE HAVE JUST
FILED A BRAND NEW LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE ADMINISTRATION AND
HAS TO DO WITH THIS VERY IDEA OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A CITIZEN
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
BEING A CITIZEN IN THIS COUNTRY
MEANS YOU GET TREATED EQUALLY.
THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION THE HEAD OF THE
SBA UNLAWFULLY AND
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY DEPRIVED
AMERICAN RESTAURANT OWNERS OF
THEIR RIGHT TO ACCESS RELIEF
FUNDS BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE,
DEPRIVING THEM OF THEIR RIGHTS
AS CITIZENS WITH THIS RACIAL
PREFERENCES SCHEME.
NOW, WE BEAT THAT IN COURT BUT
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
MANY, MANY, MANY AMERICAN
RESTAURANT OWNERS NEVER GOT
THEIR LOANS BEFORE WE WON THAT
COURT RULING.
SO WE ARE SUING HER.
WE ARE SUING ADMINISTRATOR
GUZMAN IN HER PERSONAL CAPACITY
UNDER LONGSTANDING SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT THAT SAYS IF YOU
VIOLATE SOMEONE'S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS, EVEN IF YOU ARE A
GOVERNMENT OFFICER, YOU COULD BE
HELD PERSONALLY ACCOUNT BEING.
>> Tammy: WOW, GREAT.
>> WE ARE ASKING THE COURT TO
MAKE HER PAY DAMAGES TO THESE
AMERICANS.
WE'RE FIGHTING BACK AND ANY
RESTAURANT ON WHO FILED IN THAT
LAWFUL WINDOW WAS DEPRIVED, JOIN
OUR LAWSUIT AND WE ARE GOING TO
ESTABLISH IN THIS COUNTRY A
PRINCIPLE FOR EVERY BIDEN
STAFFER, YOU BREAK SOMEONE'S
RIGHTS, YOU VIOLATE YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OATH, THERE WILL
BE LEGAL CONSEQUENCES.
>> Tammy: EXCELLENT.
AND WHAT'S YOUR WEBSITE SO
PEOPLE KNOW HOW TO REACH OUT
OUT.
>> A